modern role-playing games didn't just
arise from the digital ashes no they
stand on the shoulders of adventures
like Ultima 7 I have the beholder
Baldur's Gate and Planescape torment
developer obsidian entertainment
well-known for RPGs ranging from Knights
of the Old Republic to to Alpha Protocol
knows its history and with pillars of
eternity it hopes to recapture a piece
of it whether or not pillars of eternity
has the same magic as Baldur's Gate the
game which it clearly looks upon with
reverence isn't yet clear several
members of the game's development team
showed off the game to me recently and
it only took a single glance to see that
pillars of eternity is based on
Bioware's classic it doesn't take place
in the Dungeons & Dragons universe but
pillars nonetheless looks and feels like
its inspiration the environments have
that hand-drawn grittiness that gave the
infinity engine games an air of
fantastical despair selected party
members are identified with pulsing blue
circles under their feet and combat is
in that pause and play style that serves
as Boulder's gates signature as I
watched obsidian play pillars of
eternity it was hard not to shake the
concern that stayed with me throughout
the demo that this was not a game
standing on the shoulders of giants but
one relying on slavish devotion it
didn't help that I just played the
excellent divinity original sin an RPG
that uses its inspirations as a
springboard rather than as an exact mold
this pillars of eternity use old
mechanics to say something old and if so
is that necessarily a bad thing pillars
of eternity project director Josh Sawyer
doesn't think so we chatted a bit about
the baldur's gate legacy and the ways
obsidian plans to differentiate their
game from its forebears and four Sawyer
a big part of that is rethinking how
classes function for instance rogues are
the most offensively powerful weapon
based characters that's a change from
2nd and 3rd edition D&D where they are
mostly skill based the demo included
pillars of eternity z' character
creation which
me to get a good look at the games
classes in addition to its fantasy races
a hora is an original world and while
some of its races are familiar enough a
few of them captured my imagination the
godlike race in particular intrigues me
the godlike I saw looked to be wearing a
tall pointed headpiece made of tendons
and cartilage though apparently this is
no headpiece but rather a part of the
God likes Anatomy the gameplay I saw was
comforting and familiar as the Barbarian
and his companions ventured into the
nearby ruins there was one modern twist
however events were described as they
occurred by handsome hand-drawn story
panels story decisions aren't relegated
just to these panels however frenching
conversation trees also play a role in
the continuing story and like with most
games some of those options might be
available only if you've reached a
certain threshold and skills like
honesty diplomacy and passion but while
you can usually assume that unlocked
options are always the right answer in
other role-playing games that's not
always the case in pillars of eternity
you'll need to pay attention to the
conversation as well as to the context
it appears in the demo closed when the
adventuring party emerged into a nearby
ruins where a giant warring magical
device awaited them I was left wondering
if pillars of eternity will refresh
role-playing traditions or simply
replicate them and whether pure
replication is a bad thing at all
nevertheless I have faith not just in
the strength of the Infinity engine
template but in obsidians ability to use
that template to craft a journey worth
taking